you're listening to inside of you with
Michael Rosenbaum I hope you had a
wonderful week and uh thanks for
listening to the podcast if you're a big
Michael Bean fan you never heard of
inside of you well I hope you stick
around
um I think people you know tend to stick
around if they like an episode maybe
subscribe
um our handles are at inside of you
podcast on Instagram and Facebook and at
inside of you pod on the Twitter and uh
really appreciate you you know we've
been doing this for years now and uh we
get really good conversations with
guests and they open up about mental
health anxiety life
and um yeah I hope you stick around and
uh it seems like it helps a lot of
people it helps me helps me with my my
anxiety and my life
and uh Ryan's here yeah I'm here
still going to therapy still going to
therapy good for you Ryan good for you
had an appointment this morning yeah did
it go well it did it did it probably
yeah what no I mean it's uh it's kind of
like oh what happens when uh when when
you guys do the better help ad uh
Tommy's is he usually says like uh I
don't usually don't want to talk in the
morning but then uh get going and it
helps
it does that's the thing it's like you
think you don't have anything to talk
about and once you start talking within
10 minutes boom floodgates open and
you're like oh my God I'm so thankful I
did this you just you just feel better I
do yeah um yeah it's groovy
uh we're gonna be doing a lot of cons
this year Tom and I so if you haven't
seen a Smallville nights or haven't
visited us at a con you got to do that
the Smallville nights are great events
uh we read old scenes with fans uh it's
really private there's prizes
it's it's it's wonderful
um everyone who goes says you have to do
this so hopefully you know we're going
to be all over the country
um I'll be in Wales I'll be in
I'll be all over I'll be all over so you
gotta come also if you want to go uh if
you go to talkfillpodcast.com
um you can get original artwork signed
by me and Tom these awesome pieces of
Art and there's a limited Supply there's
only 55 million then they're gone in
their autograph I mean Tom go to
talkvillapodcast.com if you want some of
that merch the inside of you online
stores there we got new Smallville
octagonal ship Keys signed by me we also
got the regular ones that don't say
Smallville we've got leximus scripts and
uh a bunch of cool tumblers yellow
inside of you tumblers for coffee mugs
all that stuff and
last but not least
um join patreon and really support the
podcast without my patrons I I wouldn't
do this period they really um
they really support me and keep this
podcast going
so go to patreon.com inside of you and
I'll try to message you soon and you
there's a bunch of perks like your name
getting shouted out on the podcast boxes
of merch from me with notes All That
Jazz
um so there you have it uh we got a
great guest today on the podcast
yeah legend legend I have the poster up
there I actually took that poster off
it's an aliens poster and I had it I
took it apart and had him sign it
because he was the only member of the of
the cast from aliens that hadn't signed
it
and Michael Bean signed it
uh I feel like we're buddies now we text
each other
um
I just like how raw and really is and
just lets it all out there I mean you
are going to hear
him speak from the heart
I mean he just says this is how it was
this is who I was didn't like this
person enjoy this I mean he's just I've
never seen some he reminded me a lot
like Robert Patrick in the sense that it
was like old school like hey this is
what you're gonna get [__] this is
what you're gonna get this is me and
here I am and I put myself out there and
let you know that this is what this is
my life
and I love that just
I really appreciated him so uh without
further Ado let's just do it man let's
get inside of Michael Bean it's my point
of view you're listening to inside of
you with Michael Rosenberg
[Music]
inside of you with Michael Rosenbaum was
not recorded in front of a live studio
audience uh when I was a kid and I was
just like uh starting to start to make a
little bit of money and uh
you know I went to a blackjack table
took a hundred dollar bill threw it out
there
played my hand
busted and that stick came out and
pulled that 100 Bill 100 Bill back
and I I just said you know
it's back in the mid 70s
I
I probably
could have had a lot of fun with that
hundred dollar bills here 100 in Vegas
what year was that I don't know 78 so
100 bucks is probably like a thousand
bucks well it was it was enough that uh
I know that um I could have had a little
bit more fun with a hundred dollars in
Vegas than just watching somebody take
it from me and I've never really gambled
since I never that don't I can't but
with friends I I've got a deal going you
know Doug Stanhope yeah wow great
comedian yeah yeah yeah Doug and I are
best friends uh boyfriend and and
boyfriend are are our wives like to call
us I met him when I went to Bisbee when
I when moved to Bisbee he saw him do a
show or is that I've been following uh
Doug for
um probably 20 years right and I've
always loved him him Louis C.K Bill Burr
of course
um Ricky Gervais uh those are kind of my
guys that I just love uh but Stanhope
was always uh my favorite and so when I
moved to I knew he's in this because he
talks about this being his act and uh uh
so I was hoping to get a chance to meet
him and I finally did we fell in love
because he has such a dark sense of
humor you like that I I was mine works
well
yes
um but he thinks I'm funny for some
reason he thinks I'm like hysterical why
is that I don't know I don't know you
think you're funny I can be in the right
in the right circumstances it all
depends what I'm talking about you know
I can be funny I'm not um I I'm
certainly not a comedian who can be
funny on you know like this but if I'm
telling stories about my life people
have a tendency to to smile every once
in a while the people usually when they
hear these stories are they shocked at
some of these things that you've done in
your life probably yeah I've you know my
life is um is yeah yeah no it's been
it's been a wild wild ride and a great
one I mean a great one and
um but it's been wild right right from
the time that I'm I moved out here when
I was I was about 19. I'll get you
through the the early stuff quickly
because I've heard your podcast
I was born in Alabama yeah they're in
rookerville yeah we were talking about
like Michael Rooker your old buddy from
Tombstone I'm trying to get in touch
with him because I want you to tell a
Rooker story because on the podcast he's
you were listening to it yes Rooker says
um no no I don't get angry if I get
angry I get angry like I'm acting angry
I'm acting angry and then you started
laughing because you were listening to
that and you said that's [__] ask
him about come on well I I don't know
about any I don't know
about other times but I know is it funny
but you know dude when he was on
Tombstone and when he blew up George
cosmatos uh and he got in
georgetownato's face um I don't think
that was for effect
I don't you know what happened
at George cost models was an idiot I I
basically uh George cosmodels replaced
another director Kevin jar on that movie
right and George cosmatos uh just was
uh brought in
um and nobody really liked him I have
everything he's still alive no he's dead
and uh uh he
this is the truth I met him
I said I said five words to him the
entire time I made that movie and he was
he was the director on he got credited
for directing that movie
I I met him I said hello
and he started talking it was you know
around a couple of other people I just
said hello and uh and then the next day
I watched him directing the way he
treated people uh and
um the next time he approached me
um I he said Michael and I said go [__]
yourself
and that was the only five words I ever
said to George cosmatos
go [__] yourself go [__] yourself based
on just what you're my observations of
the way that he treated people on that
set you know he would say things like
yeah tell the uh extra with the big tits
to to take two steps forward you know
and whoa he was a guy that
if you were above him on on the food
chain he'd kiss your ass so he he he
tried to kiss my ass but if you were
below him on the food chain he'd treat
like [__] he found kilmery treated him
with respect of course
um Sam Elliott uh Billy Bob no all those
people they like him nobody liked him
nobody liked him well he didn't really
he didn't really direct the movie Nobody
directed it you know uh people say uh
did did uh Kurt Russell uh direct the
movie and the fact of the matter is it's
a little bit like a football team
Michael you have a coach that goes down
so the coach is gone they like the
former coach
what say that the director from before
that got fired or no that's that's a
whole another conversation I liked him
right I liked him a lot uh and um I
think he's more responsible he wrote the
script and uh he's a great writer he
wrote glory and uh he's a great writer
but he was very rigid and he didn't
understand how collaborative uh
filmmaking was especially those creative
actors well I know he had Kurt Russell
who's been a movie star since he was
like five
um he had Val Sam me Powers Booth Powers
Booth and I had a great time yeah that's
intimidating by the way well well it's
not Tim I mean that coming in as a
director you have to kind of have that
maybe that's what this new director was
like I'll just be a [__] badass and
people treat people like [__] because he
was insecure nah he was just he was just
an [__] yeah he was just an [__]
and uh uh but that you know that movie
uh came out uh uh you know they they
waited four weeks into the shooting of
that movie to
um fire Uh Kevin jar
so you see if you get a director there's
problems you know there's arguments or
creative differences you know a weekend
or whatever we had three months to shoot
that movie in four weeks in they fired
Kevin John they used none of the footage
that he uh
uh that he shot so there's a lot of
Tombstone that got cut out before we
even shot it there was so much uh with
the Cowboys with me and Powers uh that
got cut out of the movie uh and and uh
all the girls all the women in the movie
all their stuff got cut out all the
wives uh the Love Story which was you
know that was a big part of the movie
that got cut out on set when this new
director just pops up and are you guys
this movie's not going to go anywhere
this is going to be a piece of [__]
here's the thing here's the thing about
it uh Michael for me
um I can only really concentrate on on
the character that I'm playing and I
don't really have I don't have any
control over what happens and
um uh I don't really give a [__] about
morale I've you know I'm there I'm gonna
be good and and and that was a really
great character the character was great
because
their other characters in in in the
movie like like Valkyrie oh Johnny Ringo
the fastest gun in the blah blah blah
and uh Kurt says to him at the end of
the Moon what's Johnny what's wrong with
Johnny oh he's got a big hole in his
heart and he's you know he's sorry he
was born and uh Powers Booth at one
point says something along the lines oh
God knows what's gonna happen to this
group when when Johnny Ringo takes over
so I've got all the other actors talking
about how crazy I am
I really don't have to do very much you
know I don't really have to do very
right but I knew it was a good role I
mean you read a script and you see a
line like I want your blood and I want
your soul and I want them both right now
and like you know you look at that you
go wow you know I can't wait to see that
line yeah but there was a lot of stuff
that got cut out of the movie and it
what the movie ended up being was just a
smaller have you seen it yeah yeah yeah
oh Tombstone who hasn't seen Tombstone
well uh it's been years but it's one of
the best movies yeah well we got started
talking about it because it's a Rucker
and uh yeah yeah and see people ask me
about uh Val and and you know Rooker was
one of them
he was herps he was one of them
me Powers Booth Stephen Lang
uh uh John Corbett uh we were the
cowboys and so we
we all hung out people ask me what Val
Kilmer's like I go I know I have never
met Val Kilmer you never met him I don't
give a [__] about Val Kilmer you never
met him never met Val Kilmer I never met
him I got you we never we we never left
you were just talking to his character a
character's character character to
character and we went out we shot the
final scene in the movie that I'll beat
your huckleberry that scene we went out
because by that time George had been
fired we went out and rehearsed that
because Jim Jack's a producer was a
great guy just no longer with us he
suggested that we go out and rehearse it
so he got in his car and went out to
this to the location and I got my car
and went out to the location and you
know we got out of the car and there was
hey there's no there was never hey Val
hey what's up would you do none of that
it's like okay
did you want that it's just what happens
Michael you know like that's like I hung
out with Powers Booth I didn't hang Bill
Paxton and I had done that was a fifth
movie we'd done together right but and
maybe it was because we were young
younger but
um you know he
they were it was them against us and you
know I got really nothing to say to Bill
I got you know I got Kurt on the other
hand kind of he held that movie together
when they fired the director and brought
George in and and and Kurt's a wonderful
guy he's a great great personalities fun
he's got a great laugh uh obviously a
wonderful actor has been a movie star
since he was 10. uh you always hear
about people talking about uh actors who
um young actors growing up in the
business and I always get all [__] up
or whatever not Kurt Kurt you know Kurt
yeah he was yeah I guess so I mean I it
you know that's not not part of my life
but uh there's a there's a part of me
like you know when I go on set you want
the other person you want the people to
be oh this can be fun this is gonna be
but it sounds to me like this movie was
just like don't expect to make friends
do your [__] part I'm there to make a
movie to be great and if they don't want
to be like that that's not going to
affect my performance
well they don't
you know I don't here's the thing about
making movies it's a collaborative thing
and I I don't I I'm not gonna do
anything I'm not going to try to
undercut anybody you heard Robert
Patrick talking about some movie he was
on where some actor was trying to
undercut him I think we know he was
talking about right but you know I I
never I've never in my life thought like
uh you know if I stood over here maybe I
could take something away from this I've
never done that nor do I ever see
anybody do it to me and if I even think
that you know somebody does their off
camera so they're not really paying
attention you're not doing their
off-camera that well I'm just like [__]
you I don't need you to do off-camera
I'd rather you you know if somebody's
just kind of a lot of times off camera
I'll just go like just you move out of
the way and I'll do it to air I'd rather
put a piece of tape
exactly better performance because
they're not giving me anything I don't
be distracted by the [__] and with
me it was distraction and you hear
people ah you're in my eye line can
everybody move out my eye line I'm like
[__] you get in my eye line do jumping
jacks behind the the shot Jesus
I've been doing it you've been doing a
long time 50 years
50 [__] years 50 [__] years 48
.
[Music]
inside of you is brought to you by home
Chef uh if you guys are listening if you
know me I uh I don't cook I don't cook
well I don't follow directions and
there's a company that just came along
that makes it easy for guys or gals or
People Like Us who just can't get it
together and need life to be a little
easier it's home Chef
um
because we make thousands of decisions
every day and by the end of the day the
last decision we want to make is what's
for dinner that's where home Chef comes
in all right say goodbye to meal
planning recipe induce stress and last
minute grocery store runs and let home
Chef bring simple delicious home-cooked
meals right to your door
you know the problem with
making your own meals without home Chef
is that you go to the grocery store and
then you get you know all these
ingredients that you think you need and
then you come home and they sit in your
refrigerator or freezer and they rot
because you get too many too much angry
too many ingredients or you get too few
you get and then a weeks later like I
spent so much money I didn't even use
them half this stuff not with home Chef
home Chef makes your nightly routine
easier and more exciting with a wide
selection of delicious meals that arrive
at your doorstep in the form of fresh
perfectly pre-portioned ingredients in
an easy to follow recipe card with 30
unique and flavorful Chef curated meal
options available each week home Chef
ensures your taste buds will never get
bored home Chef will recommend meals
based on your selected preferences with
plenty of menu options to fit any
dietary needs looking to master the art
of cooking check out their classic meal
kit options complete with Chef written
step-by-step instructions don't have
time to cook have a hot delicious meal
on the table in a snap with quick
Solutions like their 15 minute recipes
microwave meals and oven ready options
that save you time and effort in the
kitchen plus cleanup is a breeze yeah
isn't that important Ryan yeah oh my God
that's the worst part of cooking and
have specific dietary needs explore carb
and calorie conscious menu items
customize your proteins or swap for
vegetarian friendly options look what I
love about this thing this meal service
is it's there for you it's fresh
everything's in front of you it takes no
time at all for a limited time only go
to homechef.com slash inside for 75 off
your first box
again go to homechef.com
inside for 75 off this show is sponsored
by betterhelp when you're at your best
you can do great things but sometimes
life gets you bogged down and you may
feel overwhelmed or like you're not
showing up in the way you want to
working with a therapist can help you
get closer to the best version of you
because when you feel empowered you're
more prepared to take on everything life
throws at you
and who couldn't use a few better coping
skills to be able to handle all of
life's curveballs look
if you're thinking of giving you therapy
a try better help is a great option it's
convenient flexible affordable and
entirely online just fill out a brief
questionnaire to get matched with a
licensed therapist and switch therapist
anytime for no additional charge better
help can help you be the best you
possible try it today if you want to
live a more empowered life therapy can
get you there visit betterhelp.com
inside today to get 10 off your first
month that's better help
h-e-l-p.com slash inside
really quick I got to hear the Rooker
thing well the Rooker thing was
basically well there were a couple
things when you know I was doing my
research uh because I knew I was going
to do your podcast so I figured you know
and listen to guys kind of my age So I
listened to Robert Patrick and fickner
and and and and and Rooker and I didn't
listen to all of them all all of the
show but I list to Rucker enough to
laugh at a couple of things that you
talked to him about and one of the
things he talked to you about was the
fact that uh you said Do you ever
Michael do you ever get like just angry
you ever get like you know just really
really pissed off
and he said ah
well sometimes I just act like I'm
pissed off you know for for effect and I
just I I heard that and I just had to
laugh because uh uh I've known Michael
since we did Tombstone and he and and he
directed uh Jennifer in a play my
beautiful wife Jennifer yeah who uh I've
I've heard about you for years yeah uh
because you used to date Danielle and
they used to yeah that whole thing and
uh and so anyway he's like well you know
sometimes I just act like I'm angry and
you're like oh so you're not really
you're just at yeah just act like I'm
angry because you know I want something
done or whatever and I I just laugh
because I've seen Michael
totally lose his [__] [__]
when we were doing Tombstone next time
you have them on uh you have to ask him
about George cosmatos and when he was
doing
um uh when he was in George cosmato's
face uh was that just for effect I'm
just wondering if that was for a fact or
if he was really anxious he were you
like holy [__] you can hit him
not you you never know with Michael you
wage that and listen we've all been
there I've been there before I'm no
saint when it comes to
um uh he's a Christian Bale who had the
rant
um oh yeah I've had a rant like that his
last mine lasts for like usually five or
six seconds right they don't last for
like a minute and a half or whatever and
I usually think they're valid uh but I
was you know I used to
um
I want things right I want things to be
right and it's usually not about another
person it's about the material and the
material not being right or moving on
when when you haven't got what you
really need
um so you let it out on James Cameron
didn't you no never not once no no no no
no no because Jim when I when I first
met Jim I came in I auditioned uh for
Jim for uh the Terminator him and Gail
heard and uh
I got the part and uh at that time I was
the most experienced player around I
mean because Arnold hadn't done anything
he'd done Conan and then um Linda hadn't
done much uh even Stan Winston the the
great special effects guy on that show
had he was pretty pretty early in his
career
uh
uh I think Cameron wanted Dick Smith
originally and Dick Smith I'd worked
with before so anyway I I was was very
very experienced and uh not very
experienced but uh kind of experience
yeah quite a bit of work by that time
when I was 28 I started working when I
was 22 and uh 21 or 22. and
um the thing about Jim is what happened
uh Arnold's option got picked up to go
do uh Conan the Barbarian two I'm not
sure what the name of the second one is
and so
we were we're ready to go ready to start
shooting and when that happened we got
we got pushed
so we had to spend like four months
waiting for Arnold to finish Conan the
Barbarian by that time I'd already been
cast by that time I got to know and so
during that four-month period of time I
I got I got to know Jim and Jim uh and
Stan I spent loads and loads of hours uh
with them and watched them work and you
don't have to be around Jim Cameron
um very long to understand that you're
working with somebody who uh is very
special uh is uh uh incredibly creative
incredibly smart and driven driven like
nobody I've ever worked with before and
nobody puts it in as many hours nobody
cares as much uh he sets the bar High
Michael you know I think he you know
that
uh I did three movies with him uh aliens
the abyss Terminator two no Terminator
Terminator yeah yeah and aliens and um
the abyss right and that a little part
in T2 that got cut and put back we'll
get to this because you didn't you get
paid for that
let's get back stay on the camera stay
on camera
inside of you is brought to you by
rocket money listen you you have to do
this I'm telling you you have to do this
because you're going to save money
you're going to save a lot of money all
of us do this
with the subscriptions Ryan we buy
subscriptions because we want to see
that one series or that one movie and
then we'll cancel it and what happens
we don't cancel it and months go by and
we're like oh I still have uh the
Survivor streamer it's those free trials
the fridge rope you in they get you they
get you I know it's free for 30 days
you're like oh and then you forget
it's not nothing's free folks most
Americans think they spend about eighty
dollars a month on subscriptions when
the actual total cost is closer to two
hundred dollars a month if you don't
know exactly how much you're spending
every month you need rocket money rocket
money formerly known as truebill is a
personal finance app that finds and
cancels your unwanted subscriptions
monitors your spending and helps you
lower your bills all in one place the
average person is around 12 paid
subscriptions think about that for a
second if you think you're only
subscribed to a handful of services you
might want to double check with rocket
money you can quickly identify and
cancel all of your unwanted
subscriptions rocket money will quickly
and easily identify your subscriptions
for you so you can stop paying for the
ones you don't want simply find the
subscription you don't want and press
cancel and Rocket money will cancel it
for you no more long hold times for
customer service or tedious emailing
back and forth rocket money makes
canceling subscriptions as easy as a
click of a button and over three million
people have used rocket money saving an
average person up to seven hundred and
twenty dollars stop throwing your money
away cancel unwanted subscriptions and
manage your expenses the easy way by
going to rocketmoney.com
inside that's rocketmoney.com slash
inside
rocketmoney.com slash inside
this podcast is brought to you by Dove
men plus care guys do you get distracted
during the day thinking about your
underarm sweating or itching or emitting
an odor oh do those thoughts keep you
from showing care when it counts new and
improved Dove men plus care
antiperspirant with 72-hour sweat and
odor protection and one quarter
moisturizing cream helps you forget
about your underarms so you can be
present for the moments that matter
don't let underarm insecurities keep you
at arm's distance from the ones you care
about buy new and improved Dove men plus
care antiperspirant wherever personal
care products are sold this message is
sponsored by discover did you know you
could reduce the number of unwanted
calls and emails with online privacy
protection the latest Innovation from
discover discover will help regularly
remove your personal info like your name
and address from 10 popular people
search websites that could sell your
data and they'll do it for free
activate in the Discover app see terms
and learn more at discover.com online
privacy protection
so uh you know Jim uh he sets the bar
High yeah so if you want to come play
with Jim Cameron you better be prepared
to uh
do your best and I think that's all he
ever asks from anybody is their bat
their best I don't I've never heard Jim
lose it it's real one story oh well okay
but it is one story is it firsthand oh
yeah and he's he was right though well
he's always right there was a there was
a moment have I told that story Tom
Arnold told me this story about True
Lies he says he's in the car
and
Schwarzenegger's really late
and they get in the car and Cameron
comes up to him
and just says
you're [__] my day man you're [__]
my day you come up here late God damn it
I don't want to see you [__] he goes
off on him for about five seconds ten
seconds walks away articles buddy
[__] why don't you punch him in the
face for that he goes because he was
right yeah you know I
I don't know where you heard that I
don't know if you heard that story I
read it because I read that story myself
I read that and that I'm sure happened
and I'm sure that that that that Jim
could could have lost it my experience
with him is that
um
uh he's intense he wants things right
and he wants things done his way now and
you know there was a time and I've I've
told this story before I'm not sure but
I've told people that have done
interviews with me before he'll say
things
um on a set like uh to a crew member
don't help
don't help you know okay you know
meaning just you know walking right away
yeah you're not you're not helping
instead of saying it he'll just say
don't help yeah but when there was one
time when when I was working with him
and uh well during the Terminator and
we're doing something and we do a take
or whatever and he said Michael that's
exactly what I don't want
and
um you know the hair on my back of my
neck went up a little bit and by this
time I'd spent much with him and I said
well okay Jim
uh here's the deal everybody on this set
knows
that you can do their job
better than they can do it
but you can't play Kyle Reese so give me
a [__] line reading and let's move on
and he did and I did and that's all
there is do you remember the line
come with me if you want to no I don't
no I don't remember the particular one
you know what's funny you say that is I
love it when I'm trying to get something
versus no no put the episode no just
give me the line reading I don't care no
ego here what is it I don't want any of
you to come here great just like that
and that's it I don't want to go through
of what I think you want or trying to
just tell me what you want sometimes
that's easier well I in that case it was
one in which
um
uh Jim is is blunt uh which I I would
call him blunt yeah uh he doesn't coddle
actors does he say hey Michael great job
on that take oh yeah oh he will oh oh
yeah oh yeah because I think that's okay
and most times uh as an actor for me you
know it or you look over to Jim you good
I'm good you look at you with a smile
yeah yeah yeah no he's a I think he's I
think he's I you know I haven't seen Jim
for probably a year before covid
um but he's been um
and even though I haven't seen him in
four years Michael if if if right now
I picked up your phone and I'm not going
to do it but picked up your phone and
said I need to speak to Jim Cameron it's
an emergency I need to speak to you
Cameron he I he would get I would hear
from him in 10 or 15 minutes
and he's that kind of guy you know he's
that kind of friend uh but he's not the
kind of guy that you hang out with he's
not the kind of guy that you go you know
watch a football game with or go out and
have a couple beers or stuff like that
he's he's a machine he he he's
right he's a genius for one thing and
all
and
you know
he he's just not the hanging out kind of
guy he's too busy writing
um you know the next Avatar he's too
busy I got so many stories about
um you know working with him uh I'll
tell you one and that is uh when we're
doing um Terminator last day of
Terminator uh we should we We wrapped on
a Friday night you know it's Friday
nights go into like whatever yeah I was
beat I was be he's putting in twice as
many hours as I am I'm putting in 12.
he's putting in 18 throughout the entire
show I'm beat I'm totally beat I get a
call on Sunday from Gail Hurd his future
wife and she said hey Michael Jim has
got a rough cut of the uh techno honor
which is the gunfight the fight between
me and Arnold in in Tech Noir if you
know the movie most people know techno
are and I he he wants to come over and
take a look at it and I was like ah
[__] man you know you gotta suck it up
yeah I'm like I'm beat I'm beat you know
so
so I I drive over the hill because I
live in the valley at the time I drive
over the hill and you know I go into his
eye Gail how are you good Jim's in his
office I walk in and Jim is there and
I'm about as far away from you as I was
to him and he's just scribbling away
he's just scribbling and working and
scribbling and working and I was like I
waited for a while and you didn't notice
me and I was like hey Jim hey Michael
hey how you doing good I'm glad you came
over and I said Jim what what I I'm beat
and I know you've put in twice as many
hours on this movie that that I have but
what are you three times no what do you
what are you doing what could possibly
be so important at this moment that I
mean he was I could tell he was intense
intensely yeah he was riding aliens
he was working on aliens that was that
was the Sunday
we wrapped on a late Friday you know
Friday goes into Saturday mornings he
was already going yeah well it turns out
I've read now that he'd already uh uh
had like 90 pages of it written or a
treatment of 90 pages and fox had
already you know uh but but Fox had not
I don't think Fox decided to let him
direct that until they saw Terminator
but they they but they they they had
they were paying him to to write the
script and he's he's always like that
he's always like that um Michael he he
never stops and I call him the
Terminator of filmmakers and he's the
only filmmaker that I know that's never
made a movie that's lost money
never and Terminator aliens
the Avatar Titanic uh two lies all of it
all of it because he because he cares so
much about it he doesn't let anything
slide that you know it's always solid
there's but there's a lot of people that
care about their movies there are a lot
of a lot of people that care about their
movies but
um you know there's uh there's nobody
that I know from a director's standpoint
that uh has been as successful as he was
I was um he he had just won the Academy
Award for uh Titanic and Academy Awards
all over the place and I was in the fox
lot and I got a note hey Jim heard you
were on the lot once you come over and
say hi and uh so I went over and um hey
Jim how you doing and we're talking for
a while and I mean we used to be pretty
close and and I I was always honest you
know when you get that successful you
get a lot of ends up get getting a lot
of people around you who are like oh
yeah yeah good ideas yeah yeah you don't
have to do that no and I didn't I don't
think that he would have wanted me to do
that but it this is uh but anyway this
has nothing to do so I go over there and
I'm talking to congratulations all these
Academy Awards and all this sort of
stuff and I say
now now what Jim I mean just one best
picture Best Director best best this
best that now how do you top that what
are you gonna do I swear to God this is
a true story the way I remember it he
was sitting at his desk okay he opened
his desk drawer and he pulls out two
scripts one is called Elita battle Angel
and the other one is called Avatar
and I was I didn't know what Elita
battle Angel meant I didn't know what
Avatar meant I didn't even know they
were full scripts too they weren't
treatments they were scripts and I
looked and I said uh Jim uh well cool
which one are you gonna do and he said I
don't know Michael I have to wait for
the technology to catch up
to the you know my idea of what these
movies should look like so he waited
after Titanic before he started Avatar I
think was like 10 years he waited to do
Avatar he did Avatar first and then
because that became such a huge Money
Maker he gave Elita battle Angel to
Robert Rodriguez who by the way is
another brilliant brilliant brilliant
guy to work with and this one was on
Mandalorian no I worked I saw him on
Mandalorian he was prepping
um uh the next show he was prepping prep
prepping the next show uh Dave filoni
directed the one that I was in and
um uh no I did a show called uh
Grindhouse right that was that was him
and Quentin Tarantino doing the old uh
old school the old thing so that was an
incredible experience because I got to
spend every single day uh with Robert
Rodriguez and Quentin and Quentin
Tarantino
is just fab both of them I mean they're
both worked with the greats man well
some I never got to work with I've met
Spielberg I got a funny story about did
you would you audition forever you know
I went into him for uh what's the
Harrison Ford what's the big one that he
did the first you know yeah I went in
and I was obviously young I don't know
oh there you go
figure yeah I'm a child well that's all
right um this is a crazy story it's a
true story and I've got a lot of
interesting stories about people that
I've met and um I went in I'm not sure
what I had done maybe the fan which was
a movie yeah yeah what I did with Lauren
Bacall but uh I went over I had a it was
a meeting they just you know I had a
good agent at the time real and always
had a motto uh yeah and uh so Ed Ed sent
me over to meet Steven Spielberg and um
so you know you got nervous you know
Michael do you ever get nervous with
these kind of guys not when I'm uh uh
just talking to them if I'm auditioning
for somebody yeah of course I get
nervous when I'm uh on a movie Set uh
first day of work or if I come in and do
an episodic or if I come into somebody
else's set that's been doing it for
years and yeah I get nervous sure yeah I
I still have nerves uh but when I go in
to meet somebody I you know I'm just
going to be me right and there's nothing
you're right it's a lot easier yeah I'm
not like trying I'm like oh you can
either like me or you don't like me and
so I went in I got a funny story about
Paul Schrader too the director but I
went in to meet him and uh he was over
at Universal and was on a sound stage
and there was nothing in the stage
except for in the middle of it was a
kitchen and a kitchen like uh like the
French chef kitchen you know where they
you would think that they would chew the
cooking this is way before cooking shows
and stuff or whatever right so I'm let
in and I'm like he's over there and I
walk walk over and Steven Spielberg is
there and he's got like a like he's got
an apron on he's got flour all over he's
got a hat he's got his fly he's got
flour all over him and there's a guy
there and he's like making cherry pies
and I'm like hi Mr Spielberg my name is
Michael Bean hey Michael how you doing
and we talked for
probably 20 minutes I think that he
realized very quickly on I was
too young for the role I think Harrison
Ford's got a few years on me I was too
young to play that role but uh he he was
very nice and and and wonderful but the
entire time I was talking to him he was
making pies and he was you know you know
squirting stuff in there and doing the
edges that's so weird and I said well I
said to him Mr Spielberg when I was
leaving I said I got to ask you you know
I this has been interesting and thank
you so much for seeing me but like
what's the whole deal with with the pies
you know what why why are you making
pies
and he said Michael I find uh uh the
casting process to be a kind of uh
forget the word he used but kind of time
consuming and a waste of time at the
same time it's like you have to spend a
lot of time doing it so he he's
basically multitasking so he said uh
while I'm doing this movie I'm learning
to cook
and you happen to come in on the day
that I made that I'm learning to make
cherry pies so he at the same time he's
the same time he's talking to me which
is easy for him to do he's cooking and
you know back in the that was back in
the day before phones and all that sort
of stuff but he was probably you know uh
doing something else at the same time
well you know what's funny is I with all
the stuff you've done you have such a I
mean you've done so many amazing roles
but I remember as a kid and you're not
that much older than me but watching
your professional 16 years older 16 so
you're an older brother
but look I I there's very few actors
there's there's actors out there that
you look at and you go this is a movie
star this is an old school movie star
this is like the old old days I always
looked at you and your those
performances when you're on screen
to me it was like
I I just it's movie star the looks the
the the power the not having to do too
much the and all these movies you know
and I always wonder are you just born
cool or were you were you were you
working now listen you got the when you
were born obviously you got great genes
like you look at these roles you're like
oh my God every every girl wants you
every director wants to hire you you're
the action guy you're the you're the
brooding kind of dark but lovable all
these things were you like a were you
popular in high school were you like did
you get the girls don't lie to me
Michael I was
popular I wasn't the most popular kid in
school uh I uh
was never I never thought nobody ever
you know uh women
I've always been uh very uh afraid of
rejection so yeah yeah well but I I
really I'm like you know like I'm really
afraid of
rejection so I didn't put myself out
very much
um was I the coolest kid in school no
absolutely not was I the coolest kid in
my grade in high school no I definitely
wasn't was I uh with a group of jocks
about 10 of us that were kind of cool in
in the jot we weren't Stoners we weren't
Christians we were the jocks and in that
group yeah it was somewhat popular but
um no I don't
no and here's the thing that what you
just mentioned and that was
um
you talk about a movie star okay I
am a way better actor than I am a movie
star because there are two complete
different to be a movie star and a great
actor like Tom Hanks uh or Denzel
Washington or you know there are a
number of people that are true movie
stars I was never ever comfortable I
never had a publicist uh I was never
comfortable on the red carpet I was
never comfortable doing
um press uh uh a bit of an introvert
in that way I expressed myself I was you
know I was I was into acting I really
cared about like my part and I really
wanted to do a good job and I really
cared about that but when it came to
like doing articles and magazines and
being on the cover of magazines and
stuff like that um you know and you can
go back and find me on the cover of Teen
Beat magazine or whatever like 50 years
ago or whatever and it's not like I ever
I never did it but I just wasn't that
good and I had a lifestyle that you know
thank God they didn't have phones
when I was when I was uh 20 through
about uh 45. why what were you doing oh
I did a lot of drinking a lot of
drinking when you say a lot of drinking
was it something that you'd wake up and
drink yes
how much uh at least a fifth a day a
fifth a day of whiskey yes
how long and I ended up being vodka
because people can smell smell Whiskey
on my breath I would go on runs Michael
if I would you know if I'm gonna go work
on a James Cameron movie
um I'm not going to be drinking if I'm
going to go work with Michael Bay I'm
not going to be drinking if I'm going to
go work with Billy friedkin I'm not
going to be drinking
oh I drink while I was prepping but not
I would never drink when I was working
right you know I would never but I did
drink on on jobs but they were jobs
where I didn't really respect the
director I didn't you know it was just a
a paycheck and I could do my job just as
well as anybody else nobody ever has to
wait on me on a set and nobody ever had
to wait on me uh on a movie set you know
where's you know we're ready to go
where's Michael that never happens but
you know I used to get up uh when I met
Jennifer we were doing a movie together
and I'd get up and before I was in front
of the camera I'd probably have I have
had eight ounces of of alcohol get up
and have what I call a double Deuce most
people couldn't function eight ounces
starting their day you get tired how do
you how do you keep the energy how do
you keep the focus uh you know alcohol
works and works and works for you until
it doesn't work and I was uh I was a
good friend of um I considered him a
good friend you know George C Scott you
know George C Scott yeah okay of course
okay well George she's not in the vines
[__] yeah one of the best actors ever
yeah and George she and I did a movie uh
a TV movie years and years and years ago
and he offered me a part in the he did a
a television movie Robert holmey a
television movie uh where he was
patented to or whatever and he offered
me a role on that well we got to be kind
of drinking buddies I used to watch him
on on the set that I worked with him on
on and he used to have it's like a court
it was like a bottle that had like a
handle on it you know and he would start
during the morning and he would drink
all day long and you would never ever
see him stumble Mumble his words nothing
he just drank it was almost like an
energy drink well I don't know what is
it about alcohol that was like that you
felt throughout the day was it just
relaxed you and kind of you just kept at
that pace at that level
uh I just did it because I could at that
time in my life I yeah I enjoyed it I
felt uh when I was drinking
the person that when I was drinking I
felt that was truly who Michael Bean was
when I wasn't drinking I think that I
had barriers up and insecurities and I'm
a little bit don't say certain things
and I'm afraid somebody will and I felt
like when I was drinking that was the
true me because I didn't have
um any you know I didn't have any
filters but was that a lie that you
learned later
I don't I don't know Michael I I I I I I
I
did it for so and you know I started
when I was 15. I started when I was 14
15 I was and I was awake and bait guy
for uh
30 years you know so I was doing well
that too and you know I was I was I was
at that age during the 80s when Coke was
a big deal
I didn't love Coke but I didn't like
Coke because uh uh
one thing I couldn't get a hard on when
I used Coke right now that sucks that's
a bad drug right there why are you doing
that yeah but I seemed to I used to use
it to to continue drinking you know it
would keep me awake so I could drink a
drink more and I and I did my share what
made you stop I was killing myself
you know I always told you that did you
is it someone you listen to everybody
but everybody kind of gave up on me my
uh Jennifer had given up on me uh my
mother had given up on me uh my agents
had given up on me and I you know I've
been in four rehabs I've been in four
rehabs and not that whole AAA thing
never never quite worked for me I don't
have that good of an attention span so
like I don't even know like what the
first step is let alone the third one or
the fourth one
and it just it never worked I think I I
didn't stay 30 days in in two of them or
three of them and the last one I think I
did 30 days and uh I just I was doing it
because other people told me I should do
it uh and uh but it got to a point where
I was
uh rock bottom
yeah in my mind I was Rock Bottom my
money was running out
um uh people around me my friends and
and family just just kind of didn't want
to see me kill myself
and uh so
um I just stopped I I didn't just stop
um I had a doctor who um I spoke to
yesterday actually who uh prescribed
Xanax to me
I'd never taken Xanax before and I
started taking Xanax and I just I that
was it I just quit drinking you still
take Xanax yes but a very small amount
from do you know what a bar Xanax is two
milligrams of course all right well I I
used to take four bars that's eight
milligrams well whatever yeah now I'm
down to a half a bar and I take it at
night uh to go to sleep and uh it seems
to take I don't I think uh also Beyond
it just feeling oh hey this is the real
Michael bean I think that I had a lot of
anxiety Michael I think that I had a lot
of anxiety but I'm not good at
identifying it I'm like one of those
things right no I don't think it's a
weakness I just don't I'm not I'm not
self
introspective I don't I don't look at
myself how am I feeling today oh I feel
this way oh I feel a little bit I don't
realize that
um I
you know I don't realize you know that
that I'm having feelings until all of a
sudden you know I pick up and start
[__] drinking and then I realize oh
yeah you know you you know you were
upset or you were uh you know anxious
anxious is is kind of a big thing but
enacting a lot of it is is being anxious
and I can go back I can think of like
even going way back to when I did Hill
Street Blues at lunch time you know
going across the street and and having
three or four beers so I'd come back and
and do my job and and and and and I was
great on Hill Street Blues and I've
always been good I had one day one day
my entire life on a show with Brittany
Murphy and I can't think of the name of
it uh where it was a real train wreck
but I think it was more my and they I
basically the same home they took me
well they took me off the scent they
well and I I fought I fought the car I
ended up in a what they call a 5150
like the mental mental ward for 51 hour
52 hours what happens you just got too
drunk all right well I think it had to
do with um uh it I there was alcohol
involved Michael but uh it there was a
lot of stress when
I was leaving my second wife and and
wanting to be with Jennifer I had
children I had
um
I I was just in a lot of pain I never
want to hurt anybody my second wife I
was hurting you know Jennifer wanted me
to [__] or get off the you know and I
was right in that spot where you
shouldn't be you know there's an old
cowboy saying is you know if you
straddle barbed wire fence you know and
that's you know and so I think it was
more of a mental breakdown that I had a
mental event it's amazing it happened
didn't happen earlier well it it it is
and
um but that's that's the one day that um
uh it was the last day of shooting so
everybody was a Friday everybody had
their plans to go home so they had to
come back on Tuesday when I got out of
the 52.50 and one of the requirements of
me getting out of uh whatever they got
jail whatever they call it right that I
had to go into rehab and I think that
was the last rehab that I was that I was
in but you know that's all in the past
and uh how do you feel now like how do
you feel because when I bumped into you
in Australia we were doing a convention
together yeah and what I noticed because
I had met you years ago we had like
breakfast with Danielle and Jennifer at
some place called
something 11 411 in Studio City yeah
yeah but we just had a breakfast and
from the time I saw you there then to
seeing you an Australian person I
noticed a different person well here's
the thing but I noticed someone who now
was excited about life about excited
about what he was about to do a new
project and like it was just like I was
like oh wow Michael 12 years ago I had a
devastating stroke
a devastating stroke how long 12 years
ago what happened
uh well
um
I went to bed one night with Jennifer
and uh I woke up in the middle of the
night with a really bad headache really
bad headache went in urinated went back
to bed
got up that morning I had a uh uh job
that I was starting the next day
and I opened up my script to look at my
script and I couldn't read it it was
like Chinese I couldn't read it
I was like Jennifer
I can't read this I can't read this what
do you mean you can't read it I can't
read it I can't read this and she said
uh okay she knew immediately that
something was on thank God for Jennifer
because she immediately like you know
called my doctor uh uh drove me uh to uh
Cedars I think it was Cedars
um and at that time Michael I didn't
know my children's name I didn't know uh
my uh I didn't know who the president
was uh I think it was Obama were you
terrified no I was in a kind of a
floating thing but what happened Michael
is I got
like 50 percent of my memory back pretty
quickly
but it's taken uh
uh
till right before coven that all of my
memories come back when you have a
stroke and your brain Tears like that it
uh it it he it will heal itself your
brain will heal itself and but it takes
a long time and it's very very very
frustrating so names places streets uh
uh numbers uh
being able to navigate
um I really did not uh did not feel
um like I was back and and when I act
for instance I have to I have to act
like I've always acted I listened to you
and Michael talk about hearing things on
headphones and stuff like that and you
know I totally respect that and I get it
but for me if I can't be the way that I
used to be it it's not fulfilling if
somebody's got to feed me lines or
something like that I just I don't I
don't like it and so 10 years ago that's
uh 12 years ago that's you know what's
really stopped working I mean did I work
yeah I worked here and there but that's
when I started doing the Comic Cons
because I have a uh 19 year old son now
he was 12 at the time or not not 19
minus 12 whatever that is and I and and
my son um dassel and so I still I had
bills to pay and so um
uh I had to work and I worked on a lot
of stuff that that they would pay me
you know quite a bit of money to come in
and do like three days uh or not three
days like one day or two days and then
they use my name and stamp it up there
and put it up oh Michael Bean you know
picture of me with a gun or something on
the front of the thing right and then
you know slowly but surely you're you
you go down and um I'm out of that now I
did
um I did Mandalorian which was I didn't
have a lot of dialogue in that but I did
The Walking Dead recently and Walking
Dead I had about nine pages I had about
nine pages that I had to do and for me
Michael I I don't like to be the person
I think I mentioned this earlier I don't
like to be the person when when you're
doing a shot there are a lot of elements
involved there's the DP looking at stuff
there's a camera operator this that just
got his job there's a focus calf there's
sound there's all that kind of stuff and
any any one of those elements can [__]
up a shot and it's highly important to
me that I don't suck up a shot by going
uh sorry I forgot my line it's highly
important to me so you go over these
lines hundreds and hundreds of times if
not thousands yeah until you have it
like second nature yeah and then and but
it was for a long time Michael I
couldn't do it I just couldn't remember
anything how'd that make you feel were
you depressed no I was uh frustrated
I never
I never was well I I guess there were
times that I've been depressed in my
life and and laid around for a month or
something but um I've always worked out
I've always gone to the gym and I think
that's helped me a lot but I was very
very frustrated because every once a
year I would like you know try to pick
something up try to try to uh uh
memorize it and like I like I used to
and I just you know I couldn't do it I
couldn't do it and so I shied away and
then once my memories started coming
back and once it started coming back to
a place where I was in really good shape
confidence being uh having the
confidence as an actor is a very
important quality I think it's one of
the most important qualities to be an
act and go like yeah well this is my
[__] like take it or leave it so it took
you those doing the small roles doing a
couple Pages building it up building
that confidence up to where you can get
back to where you once were is what
you're I am back to where I was before
now because I just did I did the uh I
did the uh the uh Walking Dead and The
Walking Dead Like I said was about eight
eight nine pages and you know they did
how many shots you know so they're doing
like uh in my direction they're doing
about uh eight shots on me so I nailed
that every time and then this last
um summer this last year and last summer
I did two pieces of and and now Michael
I just call it content because it's not
um uh it's not film it's not television
it's just content so anyway I did one in
Thailand uh which was a like a prison
uh uh fighting movie had to do with that
uh I was in prison and had some children
that were trying to get me out that are
trying to get me out uh I think it's
gonna maybe end up on the parent I I'm
not sure it's called lock it was
originally called Bangkok uh lockdown or
lock up I think they had to take the
Bangkok off because we were shooting it
in Thailand and Thailand they didn't
want you know Thailand's pretty
nervous about anything that's bad and
then I went to Australia and I shot
another movie in Australia which I was
involved in uh really come from a kind
of a right right from the beginning of
helping uh the the filmmakers uh create
the character not create the character
but uh
I just helped them a lot their first
first time filmmakers and I'm very very
good I'm not I don't write scripts but
I'm very good at at writing stuff so I
mean yeah I had two you know I was
worked I worked three months on one and
uh two months on the other one and uh
during that entire time I never had to
say uh sorry I forgot my line and that
just builds confidence yeah now I'm
confident now I feel like I could you
know call Cameron up well you know I
mean
um no I mean I feel like I could uh I
could work with anybody you know and
it's not you know I these days it's not
about
um
it's not about it's not about
you know
it's not about like oh you know like oh
I'm gonna do this and and that's going
to make me you know people are gonna you
know it's like just having the
experience would I like to work with
Cameron yeah just because I like being
around Geniuses you know what I'd like
to work with uh Meryl Streep yes because
I like to work with Geniuses would I
like to work with Denzel Washington yes
because I work work with you know great
people would I like to work with Johnny
Depp I'd love to work with Johnny Depp
Michael Rosenberg
I was saving the best for last I was
waiting when it was coming let me ask
you what um
because it this is awesome what a great
story about like you know it's just like
you were you were essentially drinking
yourself to death you were essentially
like lost the confidence lost who you
were that wasn't because well the stroke
the stroke is but I'm sure there was an
accumulation of like a lot of things
that probably contributed yeah to that
yeah but
now you're 66
you're in the best shape like you've
probably been in a long time you look
confident you look you're doing all
these things what do you
what what is your goal do you have like
an idea like your agents like I want to
be up for the big stuff now I want to be
no well how do you approach that are you
just continue to want to just act and
whatever comes to you whatever comes my
way
um I've never been very good at
auditioning so uh I I usually take stuff
um to offer to me you know I went from a
period of time after I did uh Terminator
until uh 17 years without
um uh auditioning and uh and I did
um you know I didn't have to audition
for Mandalorian they didn't have to
audition for uh uh The Walking Dead I
didn't audition for either one of these
movies
um that I did pieces of content that I
did
um so I forgot what was your question no
about like what you want like oh yeah
you know what I don't I don't I don't
you're content I'm very content I'm very
content I'm content because I know that
I've got a career that already you know
when you're in a movie
like just Terminator aliens and I'm
retired I'd been like I did it I was a
movie star I thought I was gonna retire
and then you know Mandalorian came along
and there's just certain people like
John Favre that you just don't say no to
you know they'll still want to see you
yeah can you come in and and support
Rose Rosario Dawson who by the way is
[__] awesome
yeah she's going to yeah oh she's
awesome
yeah tell her right you know she she
knows how I feel about her and uh
there's just certain people uh and then
you know when I did The Walking Dead it
was Greg nicotero who had done all the
special effects on Robert Rodriguez's
movie was is now the showrunner on that
and
um so I'm not I'm not very good at
auditioning but I'm once I really sink
my teeth into something
um I feel yeah I feel pretty pretty good
and confident this is called chick
talking with Michael bean and by the way
I mean you're coming on again this is
like I I I honestly you have so many
stories and so many things to talk about
I got to bring you back on okay you got
to say yes oh yes dude like this is like
you you haven't heard any you asked me
earlier if I was funny well you haven't
heard anyone no this is this is just
epic I'm honestly sitting here going oh
[__] I should have a question ready I
don't I I just I'm listening to you and
like going and I'm imagining all the
things you're telling me it's called
[__] talking with Michael Bean these are
my top tier patrons go to patreon.com
inside you support the podcast I love
you but these are questions rapid fire
Stone Age what was it like filming Navy
Seals with Charlie Sheen was it a fun
movie to star in love that movie [__]
horrible I hated it I hated it because
it could have been Top Gun Charlie was
great Charlie was sober as a church
whatever uh Charlie was great we had a
great cast we had Pat do I get one word
or just answer no go ahead yeah we had a
great cast we had packs and we had Rick
rossowitz we had giant Wally Kilmer who
was smoking we had a Academy
award-winning DP and we had a director
who uh didn't know what he was doing
yeah yeah and uh yeah so I that was the
worst experience I've ever had making a
movie and it it you can tell by watching
it you might have liked it but you're
one of the few Roz tell me a TV or movie
quote you find yourself repeating the
most when people ask you or whatever me
yeah do you have any quote that people
say hey oh yeah oh well you know come
with me if you want to live uh stay
frosty uh I want your blood I want you
so I want them both right now now I get
a lot of stuff like that Jim and Jenny
are you planning on producing more
movies with your wife Jennifer blanc no
you know what with that was a during a
period of time where where I was still
suffering my memory and you know uh that
that was Jennifer Jennifer was always
there for me she was always able to if
we were doing an interview or something
speak for me but uh now there's no money
in it and it's a lot of hard work and so
uh yeah so probably not
um tell me a story just a quick story
about Bill Paxton that you remember that
from working with him because and and
how were you close with him and how did
him passing affect you well uh bill and
I did a movie called Lords of discipline
together that's where I met Bill and
Bill is a live wire
bill is uh he comes into a room and you
know it a lot of fun uh very passionate
knows films well uh I had worked at
Roger corman's company with with Jim
Cameron uh where I I did five movies
with him so I knew bill before he met
Louise uh
uh when he met Louise when when we were
uh right at the end of Lords of
discipline and then we went over and did
um aliens together that was the greatest
time uh that I had with Bill I mean uh
you know next time you have me on I'll
tell you uh because it's about a 10
minute story or maybe in I could cut it
down but to really do it justice and
really to do to do Bill Justice uh you
know I'll come back but he was
um uh I've he
he he seemed to enjoy life more than
other people he seemed to like eat life
and you know this smile and he was
always kind of bigger than life
and as an actor he got started off that
way and he was so great in Aliens for
being that's a little bit like Bill
Paxton without the coward part okay
that's a little bit like who Bill Paxton
was but throughout the years he was able
to bring that down and by the time he
was working with Billy Bob Thornton and
doing his television series for HBO he
was just a really good actor and his
being hired was not based on uh his
personality but he he he's an infectious
infectious person personality who um uh
I spent uh
well I spent a couple yeah I I didn't
know him as well uh before uh you know I
saw him on the 25th anniversary of
aliens and we were talking a little bit
and he started to talk to me about his
something to do with his heart and I was
listening because I've had open heart
surgery that's another
[Laughter]
he's coming back don't you worry open
heart go past these stories he's come
back go ahead he's telling you about his
heart yeah well he started talking to me
about his heart and I've got um
Rico simonini is my cardiologist one of
the best in the in in the country and uh
I I had my heart surgery done by a guy
named Bud Frazier who's more used to
doing heart transplant mine was a one
foot Putt and something I was no it was
I was born with a regurgitating valve or
a heart murmur so I've had it my whole
life but I got to be 55
52 or three or whatever it was it was so
right after
I had my stroke I don't know it was
before I don't know you know whatever
but anyway he's telling you about his
heart so he started talking to me about
his heart somebody pulled me away and so
I never had the conversation with him
because I would immediately said to him
you got to talk to my guy Rico he's the
best in the business I've had it you
know and he was aware of that and I
think he probably wanted to talk to me
about it Bill uh went to uh Cedars-Sinai
and was operated on and uh
uh my opinion is that they butchered him
and uh I think that his family felt that
way they filed a lawsuit against Cedars
which was
um uh uh finally it was supposed to go
to court last December and they finally
settled out of court uh it was a very
simple surgery what what he was doing
and he had a doctor that uh uh uh messed
it up well according to Bill according
to Bill's family he uh uh made a lot of
mistakes and I had a little bit of
inside knowledge on
on what happened and uh here's the thing
about it is
um
you know we've all got a uh uh a date
with our name on it and bills happened
to be that he nobody could have enjoyed
life more than Bill nobody could have
had more fun nobody could have loved as
much as he did nobody could have been a
better father uh he's he was human you
know he he and I used to get into some
trouble together so he was human but uh
uh one of the uh
hi and I kind of took him on as a
younger brother because I had worked
more at the time so I I would I felt
like I I helped him become from an
acting standpoint he used to go to a
acting coach that I first started with
named Vincent Chase and he stayed with
Vincent Chase right up until he died but
he didn't he didn't need to die but
you know none of us need to die were you
very upset about it it really impacts
you yeah
yeah
I yeah I uh
just because
you know we're all gonna die but
when it happens like that you know when
it happens because of violence or
because of somebody making a mistake or
somebody's hubris and thinking oh I'm
gonna try it this way and uh uh it makes
it makes it more difficult and um you
know more than anything else
um uh I miss him you know I just miss
him and even though we only spoke to
each other once or twice a year towards
the end of his career because he was
working so much and I was always working
and so but when we were young we were we
were really tight and you know he he
you know he he he was a he was just a a
lot of fun to be around and it was it's
tough it was tough to see him uh that
happened to him yeah yeah you know I'm
gonna end it on the worst thing ever
okay get ready for that I thought well
you already mentioned Navy Seals so you
did no did I oh yeah when Travolta hit
you in the balls in Greece that was you
yes I
in Greece he comes over here you want to
hear the story yes okay I had no idea
that was you well here's the deal I went
in
um the director's name was Randall
kleiser and uh Randall uh had me in and
I read for him and the producers I think
it was Paramount went over there about
five times and read for the role that
Lorenzo Lamas played in the movie
remember Lorenzo yeah so when Olivia
Newton-John and him kind of split up she
goes off with Lorenzo Lamas to make him
jealous and Lorenzo lamas's The Jock
sort of thing so therefore he tries to
do all the sports and so I read a number
of times it was obviously the number two
pick for that and I think that um
I think that Randall just kind of
thought geez Michael came in here it's
probably very disappointed let's let's
bring him in for a day they brought me
in as an actor so I got paid as an actor
like 750 dollars back then or whatever
and I came in and I I
you know I I did that scene with John
Travolta where he's trying to impress
Olivia Newton-John by playing sports
baseball wrestling and all this stuff
and I happen to be I don't know if if
Randall picked me because uh uh I was
beat but yeah I was the guy that hit in
the stomach there's also another shot in
the movie where kaneki
um uh uh pulls out the Frog yeah in in
the classroom but that that that that
that that uh shot starts on on a girl in
in the front row and it starts panning
and it pans right across me so it's just
I think it's just me full screen it's
before the scene really starts I look
like I'm about 12. and and I was like 19
or something like that and it pans
across me and then you know kaniki does
something and then the scene starts but
that's but so that was uh oh let's throw
this kid a bone because um he auditioned
well for us so many times let me ask you
lastly uh do you still get residuals for
Greece yes
I get I get resistant for everything
you've done obviously yeah but uh over
the years Michael as you well know they
they become smaller and dwindles and
dwindles and dwindles and what's
happened now because I had this stroke
and because I started doing the Comic
Cons now
you know Michael the last one I saw you
at uh was uh in Pittsburgh I believe
yeah and dude I made so much money I
made because of Terminator and alien it
is basically it's not work you just
stand there and hang out with friends
and people come up and just tell you how
much they love you
well yeah I I but that's because I did
Terminator aliens and Tombstone and the
abyss and The Rock and and and and
that's all I do is stand there and have
people tell me how much they love me and
and hand me money it doesn't suck it's
not work but I do miss like I said you
know uh so uh uh yeah I mean you know I
I I you know like life is good and
um life is good I love this um I'm not
kidding I want you to come back uh
there's so many things I want to talk I
mean I can talk to you we won't get into
it now but I'm going to talk to you
about the Rock and working under
brookheimer and working for Jerry
Bruckheimer unbelievable and Don Simpson
who I knew oh John Simpson I saw Don
Simpson two days before he died so
anyway if you guys want him back he's
coming back anyway I love this guy yeah
I'll come back let's go back anytime was
this awesome
I mean honestly I didn't ever really
even look I didn't even I just I've been
around a long time Michael but uh dude I
love this thank you so much for coming
it's my pleasure you promise me I
promise yeah anytime all right follow
this man you're on Instagram no you're
not you don't need that you see I need
that [__] I don't know they don't need
that [__] I I I no any cons coming up
uh no
not I I will let you know
um I um
but no and if I did uh Jennifer would
know she's she's my girl Friday she
takes care of me she we we're in love
and she but she I I couldn't have done I
couldn't have come back from the the
stroke if it hasn't been for her she
supported me the entire year man she
really did this is a life wonderful and
lastly when when the cameras go off and
the audio stops you're gonna sign my
aliens poster that's gonna cost you all
right
[Laughter]
my pleasure
[Music]
I loved it I love that it went long too
because it was just like so in fun and
intense and real and old school
Hollywood ones are always good yeah
always informative yeah but he just like
you know he just lets you in on his
rough past and what he went through and
a lot of things that a lot of people
didn't know
and I think uh a lot of this stuff could
go viral because I don't think a lot of
people knew about this stuff and he's
hope he opened up unless he's I don't
think he tells the world about
everything but he felt pretty open with
me right Michael you [__] I love you
buddy thanks for coming on
um yeah that was awesome and uh if you
didn't get a chance to listen to the
beginning of the show just a reminder to
uh you know subscribe to the podcast
write a review it really helps the
podcast follow us on our handles out
inside Epoch uh podcast on Instagram and
Facebook at inside you pod on the
Twitter and my new band sunspin has an
album out go to it's sunspin the album's
called Never is what it is you can find
that everywhere streaming or buy the CD
on sunspin.com along with zooms with the
band and all that stuff
and that's about it
um
yeah why don't we do what we do best
read the top tier patrons
all right go to patreon.com inside of
you and become a patron today I love
these guys uh let's see you know I feel
like I want to read a different way each
time but like it's like you know I don't
know Nancy what if I use Nancy and then
their last name they gave the initial I
I put say a word but not their last name
sure if you can keep that up Nancy
delicious Leah Savvy Sarah Vixen little
Lisa you Kiko Jill
Easy Does It
Brian
H Brian how are you
Nico Pleasant
Robert brother Jason
worth it worth it Sophie
miraculous
Kristen
killer Kristen killer Raj
come on
Joshua don't
Jennifer not now
Stacy love ya
Jamal friggin a
Janelle best friends
no
Mikey Mike
effervescent effervescent Eldon Supremo
99 more Santiago my man
Chad
whoopee
Leanne
paradoxical
Leanne Paradise there you go Janine
real
Maya
present president
Maddie Superstar Belinda Never Say Never
Dave
how long has this been going on Sheila G
money
Brad Dynamite Ray
have a great day Tabitha
too much
Tom nice
nice man should we continue how many
more 99 more a lot we get a lot more uh
Liliana just think of one as I go for
the next one you're gonna think of Talia
M I'm gonna go Liliana A's for Apple
Talia magical Betsy
Don't Stop
Believing Chad
licorice licorice Dan
neat
big Stevie W angel
my beautiful
Rhiannon C
cool Rhiannon cool Corey Crystal Dev
Nixon Michelle
acrobatical
Jeremy
Chippendale okay
Brandy
D Brandy
Daredevil
okay Camille's
sweet
Joni Mitchell Joanie baby joey Mitchell
Joey Mitchell Joey Eugene and Leah Corey
Heather
Locklear Jake Busey Megan
malali T Megan
thoughtful hmm Angela
passive free mail
Sly Orlando C Orlando City Orlando City
Caroline huh Caroline R Caroline rocks
Christine scores Eric Hammer Shane rules
Emma right on Andrew my brother zaruichi
77 Andrew
nicely done my friend
Oracle Karina
and Karina
note keeper Amanda
I don't know rule uh Reigns all right
Jen bright Kevin
Elixir Stephanie K Stephanie karate
jorel all right I've got a few left and
then we'll never do this again Billy
stupendous Jammin
jam and Jay jamming
juice jam and Jupiter Leanne juice Luna
Ray Cindy
ever Everly
Mike forget about it
Stonehenge Miss
salami
Brian lover Katie be real Aaron
Roars Kendall loves House of Jarrell
Meredith I Meredith irresistible
Charlene
uh
C
crafty crafty and Kara courageous all
right that's it we did it we did it we
got through we you can't just do half of
them and the other people know we did it
it's off the cuff we love you thank you
for being here today thank you for
listening to Michael Bean uh you rock
and uh thank you for all the top tiers
and all the love and the following and
please continue to do so and support the
podcast it means the world to me from
the Hollywood Hills in
California California I'm Michael
Roosevelt I'm Miranda is I'm also here
yes you are you're always here a little
way to the camera we love you be good to
yourself
foreign